we knew it would eventually happen and a
fox news host is now blaming cannabis
for mass shootings and specifically for
the shooting last week in texas
why wouldn't they eventually get the
cannabis they've blamed everything else
other than guns they blamed coved masks
they blamed video games they blamed
doors they blamed mental illness they
blamed coveted lockdowns and the
isolation that comes from it they blamed
wokeness they blamed i know i'm
forgetting some things but
it makes sense that they would
eventually get to cannabis and that's
now what they are talking about so let's
look at this clip of fox news host laura
ingram and look at the effort
she goes through in order to point the
finger
at cannabis here and we're going to talk
about it this is from last night's show
there's a lot here so we'll do our best
to keep up with all of it and speaking
of drugs according to the daily mail
well the new york times had originally
reported that ramos smoked pot
then mysteriously the reference was
missing from the online editions
now why is that
was it bad information
or is this the pro-marijuana bias that
we've become accustomed to
that's so powerful because billions are
on the line with it nationwide
so is the story now irrelevant
we reached out to the times on this but
they have not responded
now
when it we're going to keep going with
this
when it comes specifically to the texas
shooter one of the important questions
would be
we can talk about cannabis but if you're
going to make a claim about cannabis
are you arguing that
the cannabis made him go and buy the
guns
like was he high and decided to go buy
the guns because he was high
or are you saying that
the guns were purchased with a clear
mind
but then smoking pot made him say well
now i'm going to go and do a shooting
was he high all the time or like
one of the issues when people do this
stuff that laura ingram's doing is what
is even the claim that you're making
let's see if she makes one now the
american people are hearing a lot about
ar-15s and background checks
but they also deserve to hear about this
as well
respected medical studies for years now
have demonstrated that pot use
especially among teens can trigger
psychosis
and increase the chance that a young
person will develop violent behaviors
now
let's say that that's true and we're
going to get eventually to the science
on all of this if that were true
it would be great like let's say you're
laura ingram okay i'm buying into what
she says
if that's true
it would be great to have the
opportunity to know
hey this person smokes pot we shouldn't
let them buy guns well how would you do
that one way would be to have an initial
and periodic mental health evaluation
and during which people are asked about
drug use
and
requiring for people under age 25 who
want to buy firearms
requiring letters of sort of uh
recommendation as it were
from adults in the community and it
would give you an opportunity to find
out if this is someone who smokes pot
now i'm not even saying if you smoke pot
you should or shouldn't be able to get a
gun i'm merely saying if her concern
is that people who smoke pot not be
allowed to have guns
then why not put in some of the systems
i mentioned last week
to allow us to figure that out well but
she's against that so even this
is not something they are genuinely
committed to but let's continue
the association of mature american
citizens right
a 2017 study identified marijuana as the
single most common correlative variable
in otherwise diverse populations and
circumstances surrounding the
association of violence and marijuana
now
correlative is an important word because
as we know correlations and causations
are two different things but we'll get
back to that
reported links exist to shooters in
parkland el paso dayton aurora colorado
tucson chattanooga sacramento and
perhaps elsewhere
now a friend of the dayton shooter
connor betts told authorities that he
was a gun owner and that he had done
hard drugs with bets as well as
marijuana and acid four or five times a
week now that's essentially meaningless
in drawing drawing causation hard drugs
and marijuana and acid well it's kind of
hard to blame the marijuana in that case
isn't it from 2014 to 2015.
former new york times reporter alex
berenson has written extensively on okay
alex berenson is is a joke and so i'm
gonna i'm gonna pause this here so this
is actually really tricky because there
are actually two questions the first
question is
physiologically does using cannabis make
people more people more violent either
while they are under the influence or
in a future uh moment even when not
actively under the influence so there's
a physiological question separately
there's the question of is obtaining
cannabis associated with violence and
what i mean by that is one issue could
be
the physical interaction of cannabis thc
or cbd with the body does that cause
someone to become violent but another
would be
because the cannabis market is still a
black market in many places for
recreational cannabis
does being around a black market of drug
dealing put you near violent situations
that's that's another question which you
would really have to take seriously
these are dramatically different
questions now i'm giving laura ingram
too much credit because i'm pretending
she's like honestly talking about this
which obviously she's not
ingram cites a piece by the association
of mature american citizens that's just
a right-wing lobby it doesn't they don't
do
it it's just an advocacy group that's a
right-wing group we have good studies on
the link
between cannabis and violence
and it is true
that a number of studies have found
a slight correlation
between violent behavior
uh among cannabis users that's
absolutely true there's i mean it's just
what it is i have no interest in denying
that
they have not been able to establish any
causality at this point and additionally
it hasn't been established that cannabis
makes people not predisposed to violence
any more violent and that's a critical
thing
lastly there's no evidence i was able to
find that cannabis use makes people more
likely to commit crimes
we could imagine a scenario
where one's
threshold for aggressive behavior might
be lowered by cannabis hypothetically
but that doesn't mean that it's going to
take someone not predisposed or
interested in committing crimes and make
them go and commit crimes because
they're high but of course it's the
typical double standard because the
correlation between alcohol and crime is
off the charts the correlation between
alcohol and domestic violence is
completely off the charts compared to
cannabis it's a widely established link
and fox never talks about it because
it's not convenient laura did a bunch on
this yesterday she then brought on some
guy let's see if we can figure out who
this guy is um saying why aren't people
more more people talking about this pot
thing it was initially reported that he
was a user in fact he got angry that his
grandmother and his mother didn't want
him to use marijuana but again we don't
know more it was just mysteriously taken
out of an article in the new york times
but why aren't people in general not
talking more about the pot psychosis
violent behavior
connection
well that's a very good question
okay uh but last thought on this explain
this to me
it's not the guns it's the people so
there's no sense in banning any guns
but
it is the drugs not the people and so we
should ban drugs i mean that doesn't
seem to make too much sense to me either
science aside so there's laura ingraham
with her new shiny toy and that shiny
toy is cannabis
if you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from
fast-growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly
it's a major impact on carbon real paper
also uses no plastic packaging so we
often talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below